Speaker 1: Welcome to 2023.
Hope everybody had a good new year.
We're going to start today by talking about
the new heroes of many young men.
I'm talking about people like, of course,
Jordan Peterson.
But more recently, Andrew Tate, this guy who
goes by the name Liver King and some of the
other folks in this universe.
You know, many of you emailed me about Andrew
Tate being arrested in Europe.
I don't really have anything to say about
his arrest.
It's a law enforcement matter.
I don't know if gratitude Berg's tweet was
part of what ultimately got him arrested because
of a pizza box indicating where he was.
I don't know about any I don't have any commentary
about any of that.
But I do think it's time that I talk a little
bit more about the Andrew Tate plural.
Right.
These figures like Andrew Tate and some of
the right wing political commentators are
in that group in a particular way.
Certainly, Jordan Peterson, you know, I'm
including liver king in this and some of the
tick tock workout and supplement type influencers
because what they really are are scamming
people, mostly young men.
And it is very sad to see and maybe we can
talk about it a little bit and maybe break
somebody out of it or at least get somebody
to reconsider what they fallen for.
So let's explain what's going on, these folks.
Andrew Tate Peterson, Liver King, etc.
They're just a few examples of people who
have become popular.
To make it really simple, to simplify why
they've become popular, they appeal to young
men who feel victimized, sometimes underrepresented
in mainstream culture and society, disadvantaged,
certainly dissatisfied with either their level
of success, their amount of muscle, their
physique when it comes to, like, the liver
kings, their jobs success, their success with
women.
Do some older men follow these guys?
Yeah.
Do some women follow these guys?
Sure.
But if you go to a Jordan Peterson event or
you see who follows Andrew Tate or Liver King,
it's mostly men and they're mostly relatively
young now.
There's nothing wrong with that in principle.
That's not the point I'm making.
There's all sorts of different people whose
followers are concentrated among some demographics
and not others.
That's not the problem.
That's the context.
These types like the Tate's in the Petersons.
ET cetera.
They offer a message that is a freedom of
liberty, of men taking control of their lives
and fighting back against a culture or society
that is putting them down.
Everything about culture and society is helping
others.
It's either helping women or it's helping
people who are already wealthy or whatever.
Right.
But the thing about it is that when you look
more closely at the message, you find that
the disappointments they address, the grievances
they speak to, these are standard ones in
the prototypical self-help discourse, just
completely standard, nothing unique about
it.
And and specifically, many of them are actually
tailored to young men.
I've said before, Jordan Peterson's advice
is almost completely universal.
It's been done a thousand times, and that's
okay.
What Jordan Peterson does is he packages it
in a particular way.
The personality of Peterson, the demeanor,
the stuff surrounding it is somewhat different
and unique to a degree.
And so they take those obstacles or those
problems.
They combine it with their own delusions of
grandeur and sense of how powerful they themselves
are, and also the victimhood framing.
We're a victim.
So are you.
I'll teach you to overcome this, this victimization
that you're suffering from now.
They're all a slightly different brand or
category.
With Jordan Peterson.
It's more cultural and societal.
Well, I mean, to help you overcome the social
and societal and cultural issues that are
holding you down with Andrew Tate, it's more
overtly about how to get women and make money
in business.
And then with liver king, it's how to get
muscular and live this ancestral, primal lifestyle,
which is completely absurd, by the way, but
not the subject of this particular video.
So it's versions of the exact same thing,
the really funny thing, or maybe it's the
sad thing, or maybe it's the ironic thing
is the revolutionary self framing that these
guys do.
When you listen closely, it almost sounds
like Marxist rhetoric, except it's the epitome
of grifter capitalism.
And I'll explain exactly what I mean by that
when you listen.
Her Peterson or tater or liver king and these
others, they sort of talk like they are the
Marxist leaders who are going to fire everybody
up.
They're going to red pill you and you're finally
going to overthrow your oppressors, the capitalists
like.
But that's Marxism, except they are actually
the capitalists.
They've simply adapted a rhetoric and it's
actually working really, really well.
Liver king it's totally overt.
The capitalist grift is overt.
He's selling supplements.
It's unclear.
Liver King even takes his supplements.
He previously claimed to eat insane amounts
of raw animal organs every day.
Some emails that leaked expose that liver.
King doesn't really eat much of those organs
at all.
It's all a capitalist grift to sell supplements.
Okay.
With Jordan Peterson, it's he sells books
and does personal appearances, you know, speaking
gigs at which he gets paid.
And the language is more about take control
of your life.
Take control of it.
Don't, don't let don't let the leftists oppress
you.
Don't let those who want to compel speech
oppress you.
Don't let big tech oppress you or whatever
the case may be.
And with Andrew Tate, it's you know, he's
got his courses, his subscription program,
where he'll teach you to meet women and make
money and this sort of thing.
They are packaging almost Marxist, revolutionary
sounding rhetoric.
With this, I will give you the red pill.
I can show you the reality of reality in this
super capitalist grifter situation.
Now, this phenomenon is not limited to these
three guys by any means.
A lot of the self-proclaimed gurus who offer
quick fixes, easy solutions to complex problems,
they it's the same type of thing.
They are preying on people who are sometimes
desperate, often vulnerable, and they promise
them whatever they need to promise them.
They don't really deliver much other than
a false and sometimes temporary sense of empowerment.
And yet they continue to do really well in
our society and culture.
People are drawn to them and drawn to the
allure of the easy fix.
Now some of them have become more sophisticated,
so they tell you, I'm not going to give you
an easy fix that they've incorporated.
This is there's an iterative process with
this stuff where first it's overtly an easy
fix, and then you have the second level charlatans
who go, Listen, I'm not here to offer you
an easy fix.
It's not a one stop shop, but it's still this
sort of very prescribed methodology that is
still the idea of the easy fix, which they
tell you will be difficult.
But it's still here's the solution, here's
the solution.
And at the end of the day, what you have is
those who come to you and say, step outside
of the bubble.
I will tell you the real nature of reality
and tell you how to take control of it.
They are actually the ones suffering from
you staying in a very but in a similar bubble
to the one they claim to be getting you out
of.
That's really the scam and the grift.
And you can apply it to all of these guys
and more, you know, to some degree, like Deepak,
Deepak Chopra, although he's not as popular
now, it's a slightly different version of
it, same type of thing.
That's what's going on with these guys.
I would love to prevent people from falling
for it in the first place, and if they do,
it would be great to get them out.
But that's fundamentally what it is that these
folks are selling.
And remember, they are selling
you something.